the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones house
of the dragon video all right my friends
in this video we will be looking at
another interview featuring mr dinklage
who as you all know is famously known
for his amazing role as lord tyrion
lannister in hbo's massively successful
series game of thrones in this interview
he once again gives some of his thoughts
about game of thrones and its divisive
ending as well as hbo's upcoming game of
thrones successor show house of the
dragon while dinklage has moved on from
westeros the game of thrones universe
may be just beginning as you all know
hbo is working on house of the dragon a
new show said hundreds of years before
the events of the original series set to
air later this year let me show you what
dinklage has to say about the new show i
think the trick is not to try to
recreate thrones he says if you try to
recreate it that feels like a money grab
with a lot of sequels the reason for
them is that the first one made a lot of
money which is why they're not as strong
but i am excited to watch the house of
the dragon simply as a viewer not
knowing what will happen next now maybe
it's just me but i don't think it sounds
like he's that excited for house of the
dragon although what he said is valid we
all know game of thrones was hbo's most
successful show to date i remember
reading several financial articles that
stated hbo made billions of dollars from
game of thrones alone so i understand
why hbo wants to make another game of
thrones show immediately after the
original series ended they want to
strike while the iron is hot but we all
know they could also run the risk of
ruining the game of thrones brand if
they rush another series out before it's
ready this is basically what was about
to happen with the series about the long
night hence the reason why they shut it
down after only making its first episode
they already made one mistake by letting
dan and dave end game of thrones the way
that they did if house of the dragon or
any other game of thrones series for
that matter stumbles out of the gate in
the first season they might lose even
more fans than they already have as you
all know hbo already has to win back
over a lot of the game of thrones fans
because they're still angry with how the
original show ended in fact there are
many game of thrones fans who say they
will never watch another series from hbo
ever again millions of fans were furious
with the finale of game of thrones when
our mother of dragons daenerys targaryen
went genocidal in reference to this mr
dinklage said the fans were just mad
because nobody wanted it to be over he
also said i know a lot of the fans were
shocked by the ending but if you are
watching closely the signs were always
right there so as you can see he says
fans should have known daenerys would
have went mad by the end well i will say
what i have always said once again i
don't think the fans were angry simply
because daenerys went mad in the end i
think most of them were angry because of
how fast it seemed to have happened
yes of course there were many signs that
this would happen but it's as if a
switch was flipped in the final season
in only the span of a few episodes
daenerys went from a somewhat rational
and understanding character to one that
was blinded by homicidal rage it was
definitely a shock to the system because
it almost felt as if it happened
overnight now this isn't all dinklage
had to say about the final season if you
have seen all of my recent videos then
you know he had a lot more to say about
the fans outrage over the game of
thrones ending if you already saw that
video then you can stop this one right
here if you haven't seen his other
interview from last week i will show you
that now i think you might be interested
in this one as well although it might
leave you shaking your head once you see
what he said
for everyone else who has already saw
that interview i want to thank you for
watching this video
now if you're like me i think you will
find this to be not only interesting but
mostly annoying because i think it's
another attempt at dismissing at least
some of the fans criticism of game of
thrones season 8. let's have a look at
the new article so i can show you what
mr dinklage said about the final season
of game of thrones the headline reads
dinklage says game of thrones fans were
upset about the finale because they
wanted the white characters to ride off
into the sunset he is basically saying
that fans were only upset because john
and danny did not sit on the iron throne
together that's right he did not hold
back in a recent interview with the new
york times when it was brought up that
game of thrones fans were let down by
the show's finale he also said by the
way it's fiction he added with a laugh
there's dragons in it move on alright
now i also want to give some of my own
thoughts on what he said so far
first off let me just say this i am a
massive fan of the actor not only do i
think he brilliantly brought tyrion
lannister to life on the screen but he
also delivered some of the greatest
scenes in game of thrones i think it's
safe to say that dinklage was one of the
best actors on the show i think he
helped make tyrion one of the most
beloved characters in a cast that was
full of dozens of great actors and
actresses now with that out of the way i
also want to say that i completely
disagree with what he said in the
interview for him to say that fans were
only upset with the finale because the
gorgeous white characters weren't riding
off into the sunset together is simply
false if you go back and watch all of my
older videos you will see that i said
jon snow will never want the iron throne
which made sense because that's who he
was as a character he was never in it
for the iron throne so we would have
been foolish to think that's where he
would have ended now danny on the other
hand has a different story as we all
know daenerys was focused on taking back
king's landing as well as the iron
throne but fans were not angry just
because she didn't get it daenerys fans
were furious because of who her
character became in such a short span of
episodes she basically became adolf
hitler by the end of the series shocking
millions of fans because it seemed to
happen so suddenly they're not angry
because john and danny weren't holding
hands overlooking king's landing in the
end let us also not forget what happened
to the night king now for me this was
the most upsetting and it wasn't only
because zarya stark was the one who
defeated the night king if you have seen
my videos then you know why i think it
was a bad idea to have arya stop the
night king however the other thing that
was so upsetting about this was the fact
that the night king and his army were
defeated almost immediately after they
made it through the wall as you all know
this was something they were building up
since the very first episode of the very
first season then when the night king
finally moves south he's defeated by
someone who didn't even know he existed
before the final season you want to know
what else made a lot of us fans upset
about the final season jaime and cersei
lannister for one we were extremely
unsatisfied with how they died not only
that but i was also heartbroken when i
heard jaime say he never cared about
saving everyone in king's landing it was
already bad enough that he ran back to
cersei but by him saying this it ruins
that amazing scene he had with brienne
when they were bathing in season 3. now
don't even get me started on what
happened in dorne or what happened with
arya stark when she was in braavos
saying that the fans were only angry
because john and danny weren't sitting
on the iron throne is so dismissive our
frustration with the final season goes
way deeper than just this do i even need
to mention how euron greyjoy's character
was handled or how the golden company
was dismantled in seconds i mean the
list of criticisms could go on and on
but i want to go over some of the other
things that he said in the interview
let's go back to when he said by the way
it's fiction there's dragons in it move
on now just because there were dragons
in the show doesn't mean we should
ignore every mistake the writers made
again i can only speak for myself here
but game of thrones wasn't just some
dumb show that had dragons for me it was
much more than that game of thrones was
groundbreaking in so many ways and in
fact i think it redefined fantasy in a
way that had never been seen on
television before game of thrones had a
vast array of fascinating and complex
characters that blurred the lines of
good and evil even though the show did
have dragons and magic the relationships
the characters had with one another made
them feel real
all of us who did love the show
immediately identified and connected
with a number of different characters
and this made me care about them more
than any other character from different
shows or movies i had ever seen before
everyone else who worked behind the
scenes helped make this show and
universe feel realistic the set
designers the makeup artists the costume
designers the incredible music and so on
and so forth
let's see what else mr dinklage had to
say he said yeah was called game of
thrones but at the end the whole
dialogue when fans would approach me on
the street was who's gonna be on the
throne i don't know why that was their
takeaway because the show was really
more than that dinklage said that one of
his favorite moments from the finale was
when daenerys targaryen's dragon burned
the iron throne because it sort of just
killed that whole conversation which is
really irreverent and kind of brilliant
on behalf of the show's creators he said
shut up it's not about that dinklage
added referencing david benioff and d.b
weiss they constantly did that where you
thought one thing and they delivered
another he said everybody had their own
stories going on while watching that
show but nobody's was as good as what
the show delivered i think
wow he actually thinks no one could have
written it better than what david and
dan did
well once again i disagree
and i would bet that he feels somewhat
different as well but he doesn't want to
go against hbo because i'm sure he would
love to work there again he also said
that he felt audiences were angry about
how the show ended because the show was
simply coming to an end in general
we were going off the air and they
didn't know what to do with their
sundays anymore
they wanted more so they backlashed
about that
well my friend we were not the only ones
who wanted more
why is it ending
i don't know ask dave and dan when they
come through
um we could have gone to
11 12 13 seasons but uh they i guess
they wanted a life
you wanted it to keep going
well it you know if you've read my
novels
you know there was enough material for
for more seasons they made certain cuts
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you